so I watched the fights and and man it
was intense you know first they had I
saw Holly Holmes versus uh newness and
Holly Holm she kept looking like like
she was about to lose and then she did
and I also saw Thiago Santos or Santos
and Santos little helper brought one of
his knees what wasn't helping him that
much you know he had one of his knees
kept kind of doing that lazy susan like
you would see his kneecap would be in
the front than in the back it was like
kneecaps in the front kneecaps in the
bag
but he stayed on he stayed on for that
one-legged challenge I mean this guy I
mean he could be a tree that's how tough
he was he could be a tree because a tree
only has you know a treatise has a
treatise has one leg and I mean he was
just he was a long-haired that he was
that one-legged launchpad and he kept
launching him launching that other leg
you know he kept launching kicks and uh
those uh big boppers dude and he would
throw and he only Santos is like that
guy he's almost like the toughest blind
guy you've ever seen cuz he don't even
look when he throws he just and when you
see his arm coming it looks like a herd
of bison coming at you I mean his arm I
mean I bet his arm would test positive
for bison if they checked his arms out
and John Jones won John Jones well first
of all his arms are too long okay they
should have a arm limit they should test
his arms for other arms because in if
you look at his arm it's got it's like
three or four generations of arms in one
arm I mean he could hug you and then be
behind his own back at the same time I
mean he just it's you know it's really
overwhelming and then I watched your boy
Maz V doll and this guy he seemed like
he was ready to win that American Top
Team killer I mean he showed up and all
week he's had kind of long hair is that
kind of like you know let your hair down
kind of Thursday and let your hair down
Friday and then Saturday night he fixed
that up that masse Vidal Sassoon baby
and then he came in Saturday night with
that kind of you know he with that
flamboyant honest with that hair care
and his hair looked like it I mean his
hair looked like yeah I mean he was
really it looked beautiful it was real
he had the hieroglyphs in and he was
ready to to beat ass and look nice while
he did it and he came in who sometimes
you have an idea and sometimes it is
good and sometimes it is not and he came
in with that knee I mean just the me I
mean it was like that midnight ride of
Paul Nev ear you know and he just he and
then the Red Cross is coming the Red
Cross is coming I mean in look he's that
South Florida bad boy Mazz Vidal I mean
he was like on a new Bravo show the real
househusbands of Miami he hit him with
those with that nene leakes bruh
and he left him Nene leakin down there
on the met I mean you know when a man is
able to take a risk like that he he's on
a heavy diet of risk biscuits and and a
side of fearless fearless and his
dipping sauce oh let me get a little
more a fearlessness on that one because
that is I mean you coming in he hit him
with that nistro Thomas boy and he had
him you know asking couldn't even
predict his own future brother Sal
that's what happens look I can't even
fight I'm one of those dudes who
more likely to kind of get his ass beat
you know because those guys are special
also you know they get that's underrated
you know it's really underrated also
getting knocked down and I've done that
I've been knocked out before and you
know it's quick it's to the point at
least you're not wasting a lot of
people's time but I you know I'm glad
that Askren seems okay he had a funny
tweet afterwards well that sucked I
thought that uh you know he's very
entertaining and that [ __ ] scared me
dude when when he hit him I uh I got on
Amazon I order two ordered a wheelchair
for myself bro I was that's how scared I
was
and I'm also look I'm an own [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying but so but I hope
asked her is healthy and well and
bounces back
you know Thiago and John Jones they
really I mean John Jones is he even a
human have they do they know that he was
born on earth because he doesn't even I
don't even know what sometimes it's like
it's almost just like he's like he's
like um he's just like an a it's like
watching that it's like watching
something from another planet fight
I mean it's bizarre now all the entrance
he's got the backstage show he's got the
dance on the way out you know I'm
surprised they don't have a stripper
pole over there by his team because
there's a lot of levels of getting then
he gets in the ring he's got the prayer
honor in the ring then he's got that
Rolie Olie you know he's got that big
debt you know he just comes in there two
straight like a big flicking just like a
flipping like that dark salamander bra
and he just and then he's ready to go
but it's a long entrance I mean he put
more action into the entrance I thought
then he did into the into the fight but
also you're talking to a guy who does
not know much about fighting and uh and
I probably shouldn't even be commenting
on any of this